my name is Mark Turin I'm the program
director of the Yale Himalaya initiative
and I'm an anthropologist in the
linguist I've been working in Nepal for
20 years now I first went in 1992 as a
school teacher to work as a volunteer in
a school in northwest in Nepal and at
that point I had a place to study
languages at University and I changed to
anthropology I was fascinated by the
ethnic and cultural diversity of the
region and since then I've been working
in the Himalayas across Bhutan northern
India southern tibet and particularly
nepal one of the extraordinary things
about the himalayan region is that we
have an opportunity to study problems
not disciplines our questions and our
research questions transcend
disciplinary and also geographical
boundaries so we can work in a
collaborative way with people in
entirely different fields in
conservation biology history geology
Tibetan studies and probe really the
questions that underlie the movement the
migration the cultures of contemporary
communities in the whole Himalayan
region one example of that is I worked
intensively with a shaman and an
anthropologist and archaeologist on a
research project in north western nepal
that went back to the ancestral villages
and conducted an archaeological survey
there of the ancient settlements of this
ethnic community that thummel my also
known in nepali as the GU room and that
kind of collaboration that brings
different disciplines different
understandings to bear on contemporary
ethno political issues is very pertinent
and it precisely what we can achieve
through the Yale Himalaya initiative
over the last two years with support
from yells administration we've
established the Yale Himalaya initiative
as a truly interdisciplinary initiative
on the Yale campus that works not only
with Yale students in college but also
professional schools but with alumni and
partners in the region and of course
faculty at Yale to study in an
interdisciplinary holistic way the
issues that are affecting the Himalayan
region now we've chosen three themes but
cluster our research interests at the
they're our livelihoods environment and
culture and we believe that those three
themes transect and transcend the region
and the different issues that we want to
explore together with our partners there
there are a number of key things that
were working on right now in the next
few years we hope to be able to teach
either on-site or through a distance
collaboration with colleagues at
different universities many of the
languages that are spoken as lingua
franca national languages of the
Himalayan region we're also hoping to
explore developing our course
initiatives so we have more courses on
different disciplines that also
transcend disciplines on Himalayas that
is at Yale there's a growth in student
numbers both at the undergraduate level
and a graduate level students coming to
work specifically with faculty here
enriching the Yale collections and the
partnerships that we have at the same
time a number of us are involved in
ongoing collaborative research projects
with outside funding that bring in
regional partners and develop research
initiatives in the Himalayan region with
Yale Himalaya at the center a decade ago
when I was at the University of
Cambridge together with three other
colleagues there I established the
digital Himalaya project as a multimedia
ethnographic archive to digitize and
then return anthropological information
from the Himalayan region to the
countries of origin one of the exciting
things that's come out of that has been
my increasing realization that the
resources that we need to study the
region the Himalayan region writ large
so often are not available in the region
itself it seems miraculous at some
points that you can research incredible
amounts of detail on history language
and culture at a university like Yale or
Cambridge but those same resources were
for so long not available in the
countries of origin so one of the things
that Yale Himalaya initiative is doing
is trying to share the information the
knowledge and the resources we have here
at Yale back to communities and partners
and through a process of digitization
video documentation and cultural return
we're building the partnerships with
communities with scholars in the region
and we see ourselves as partial agents
in the knowledge transfer going back and
forth enriching collections that we have
at Yale and connecting our knowledge
with communities and with students of
interest back in the region as the
initiative grows key to its success will
be the local partners that we have in
the region for the last two summers and
this summer coming we have been
organizing collaborative workshops in
India in dehradun and that in Nepal in
Kathmandu and this summer august 2013 in
bhutan together with our local partners
and what we're doing by calling these
meetings in the region is bringing
people into conversation from across the
region who otherwise might not have a
framework for a regular consultation and
discussion now all of this is being
facilitated of course by technology we
have regular skype contact we share a
huge amount of files and data with our
research partners and our students in
the region so a combination of
Technology frequent visits and kind of
open sharing of knowledge given yells
enormously rich collections is the
future I think of Himalayan studies yell
Himalaya offers a pretty comprehensive
semester long program of Himalayan
activities here in New Haven we have a
regular speaker series where we invite
speakers from around the world working
on Himalayan studies to present on their
work and engage with students we have
regular film showings and cultural
events and also increased course
offerings so students can take courses
with explicitly Himalayan subject matter
in religious studies in anthropology
South Asian Studies and increasingly in
Forestry and environmental studies also
and we have a regular conference
schedule both here at Yale and in the
region so increasingly we're becoming a
center for discussions on Himalayan
research and teaching activities to
happen in North America I've also
accepted the editorship together with a
colleague at Dartmouth of the journal
Himalaya which is the foremost peer
reviewed journal of Himalayan studies in
North America and increasingly with Yale
at the center of these discussions we
feel we're able to grow Himalayan
studies through Yale's partnerships in
the region and also with institutions
across the states
you